the number of ADHD diagnoses has gone up
was it like 10 times 50 times or
something they say one in seven little
boys in America is now medicated those
are brutal medications you know how many
boys I've talked to and grown men who
are in their 20s that say I've been on
stimulants since I was four years old
because my preschool teacher diagnosed
me with ADHD and told my parents they
would kick me out of school if I didn't
get on meds guys have never lived their
real life I don't know whether you've
ever been on ADHD medication but from
what you know about the experience of it
what can you tell me about what life
would be like before and after most of
what I encounter is people whose brain
is so fried from years and years and
years of being doped up and zombified
and then still being screamed at any
time they twitch wrong they move wrong
they act wrong they don't do something
right it's you have ADHD that's your
ADHD get under control it's not just
even the meds it's the whole experience
of being told there is something wrong
with you and you will never function
right